I've lived a pretty unconventional life
um I'm
46 um I've been most of well the past 20
years I was in the Cannabis uh uh I was
in the Cannabis industry before it was
legal and um and I kind of phased I've
have I have a couple children now with a
very difficult woman that's another
story um but like if I'm at a point in
my life or like I feel I need to
reinvent myself um at this later stage
of life um something I probably should
have been more responsible about
earlier uh
46 okay um so what would you recommend
uh or what kind of guidance would you
give
someone um starting over at this late uh
stage of Life while having I have two
young children a 2-year-old and uh
six-year-old almost yeah um I mean I
have some
savings um and uh but yeah I'm just
trying I have a goal here again I'm
gonna ask you a question that I asked
earlier I can produce a magic wand and
wave it to solve your problem what does
that look
like uh that's a good question um well
I I would like I like the well um I have
good cash flow income um are you like
ask specifically from what no I'm asking
you what the question is so I'm trying
to get some clarity on what you need
help uh I mean if if you had a magic
wand um I I one it would be having my
children's Mother uh behave well be well
behaved um and then live together are
you married or we do live together we're
not married um but we do live together
on the edge like we don't get along very
well kind of problem you having with her
well I was the provider for I mean it's
kind of I was the provider 90% of the
provider for the past 10 years we've
been together for about 10 years and um
I kind of phased out of the industry I
was involved in two years ago and I
basically have very little income I have
some I also she's threatened me in all
kinds of ways in the past like with
police with um I don't trust her 100% so
I don't tell her all of my financials or
I have like a couple Investments and
stuff like that so oh and she just
became a Nerf she became financially
semi-independent as of about a year ago
she's now a nurse so she makes like okay
money like around a 100,000 or something
like that so she feels she doesn't
depend on me I'm a
loser um and uh what am I doing with me
myself I'm almost 50 and I'm taking care
of our kids a lot like I basically like
while she was in nursing school I was
like taking care of the kids all this
I'm like Mr Mom half I'm kind of like a
Mr Mom it's it's also hard to
income um not I just have like uh I have
a couple of Investments that are acre
interest but um not real no that's the
thing is like I'm I'm unemployed I'm
trying to reinvent myself I was in an
industry I don't have like I didn't go
to school and get degrees I just like I
was in the Cannabis industry for 20
years before that I was a floating
around hippie uh traveling the world so
when you in the Cannabis IND industry
what did you did you grow did you sell
it like what you everything okay
everything but I had some bad
experiences I no I don't anymore I I got
robbed I had some bad experience I did I
do have a cushion not a huge cushion but
an okay cushion um and uh but yeah I've
had some I had some I mean I did I lived
well for a while but um I didn't build
up as much as I should have so like I'm
like okay here's what here's what your
problem is with the relationship is
she's turned you into a housewife she
did she did she did so so she's gone off
to work she got her education she's a
nurse she's surrounded by all these
strong independent whamen now and
they're all telling her Schmo is a loser
he's a bum he's a stoner but guess what
you're the guy that probably put her
through school help I did you're taking
care of raising the kids right now she
doesn't respect you right anden she does
not right women have a very difficult
time dealing with a guy on a long-term
basis if she can't look up to him
because that's what hypergamy is you
know a guy ear ask hypergamy she's got
to be able to look up to you and because
she's gone now and she's in the
workforce and making what she considers
good money she doesn't need you she
doesn't need you but here's a good thing
because she's making the money and
you're and you're taking care of the
kids how old are the kids
uh two and six two and six so they're
still super young you're doing all of
the parenting she's doing I'm not doing
all the parenting she does I'm not doing
all the parenting I did I did more than
half now I'm still doing a little bit
more than half because now she she works
three 12h hour shifts she also teaches a
little bit in the co I I do a little
more than half okay but it's like so so
she's going to work and she's resenting
you for being stay-at-home Mr Mom right
yeah even though you know you're doing
something useful I always find it's
interesting that men are very happy and
willing to go to work and you know
retire their wives and get their nails
done and do their beauty work and give
them a [__] allowance and a Range
Rover and all this [__] but when guys
stay home they hate it they legit I'm
still I'm still paying half the bills
still I was paying all the bills now I'm
still paying half like with my savings
she's got the income you know she's the
one with the j o she's a li professional
and again remember she's working amongst
women who are all in her ears telling
her the exact same thing schmo's a loser
why are you with him how do you get rid
of this guy I guarantee you there's
conversations going on as we speak this
this week about how do I how do I get
away from this guy right so she's me
she's been asking she's been asking me
to move out and I'm like and I I started
I was like okay I'm moving out I mean I
she I think she does take the kids with
you yeah but she won't let me do that
then stay in the house I mean if you
want to be a your life if you want to
raise children if you want to have some
influence on them then stay in the
house my ahead of you my friend my other
big question
was like I want now I'm 47 years 46
years old how do what would you do if
you were like you're a rich Cooper you
don't have a a business at the moment
you don't have all these degrees or
whatever you know you don't want to do
the Cannabis industry anymore like how
would you you have some Capital how
would you reinvent yourself at this
point in life well you can watch the
entire thing unfold if you go back to my
very first video from May 23rd 2014 on
the entrepreneurs and cars Channel
because okay because it's been fully
documented there for over nine years now
so that's how I reinvented myself from
the debt settlement industry uh running
one of the most successful companies in
can but you had a lot of money probably
when you you probably had a lot of money
like money money isn't that hard to make
time is more valuable than money because
time runs out I mean we all done okay so
May 23rd EP which year am I looking for
uh just just go to the channel and then
sort the videos by oldest videos the
oldest one yeah and then there's there's
50 00 videos so you can watch the entire
evolution of me unfold if you got
nothing to do for like week straight you
can watch all those videos back to back
and watch How I evolve from that time
right okay but what I would look at is
what do you like doing what are you good
at sorry let me clarify what do you love
doing what are you really good at doing
and it also makes money and I would turn
that into a business It's tricky to make
money like because there's things I like
doing me make money off weed when it was
illegal I did I was really good at I was
really good at networking and like
having people trust me and uh you know
there is like a whole I mean I heard
Elon Musk said that like a drug dealer
is more has more more knowledge of
running a business than like someone who
went to school or whatever so like I
don't know if that's they have real
world
experience yeah
yeah but it's it's acting on it right so
so I mean if you're sitting around
getting Stone like do you still smoke
weed a lot I don't smoke weed at all
actually I've never been a stoner this
even though I was in the industry I was
growing it and everything I was never a
stoner Okay cool so just just figure out
again what you love doing what you're
good at and what makes you money and
then double down on what will work for
you there go and go and create your own
business I mean dude she's at work
bringing home the bacon and as far as
you're concerned right now she's not be
she's she's not she's bringing home half
the bacon she will not she will not
right but you're looking savings though
yeah so I'm bleeding half my savings
every month I mean half
of are you are you living off the
interest off your savings or are you
living off no I'm going I'm eating
beyond the I'm going beyond the interest
like I so so how many months or years
you have left in Runway no I mean I I
probably I probably could go another
four years okay well that'll run out in
four years and then what do you do that
I know I know I know it could run out
quicker too but
yeah basically got three or four years
to figure something out while she
chirping you calling you a bum making
fun of you telling you to move out but
she is very I wonder if I like she is
very she's become very abusive like um
it's because she doesn't respect you see
I know but before dude the the the
countdown to the end of a relationship
is contempt as soon as a woman shows
contempt for you like she start you she
insults you she's doing all of these
things and the frequency of the contempt
and the volume of the contempt has a
bearing on the countdown of the end of
the relationship do you guys feel
day uh I mean we not consistent enough
we had like where there's a like a three
months ago I was going to move out I was
like okay I'm moving out fine see you
later and then she switched and then we
saw that was going on then there was
banging going on and then she turned
into a [__] like three weeks later
again she didn't last like so she still
for a way out she's looking for a way
out dude like you like at the end I I
was leaving she was looking for a way
out I said okay I'm leaving see you
later moving out and then she was like
actually no she changed her mind and um
so I mean you do something freaky in the
bedroom that
night not particularly like we we are
we're like kind of like
vanilla Plus hear me out here dude this
the the the clock is counting down to
the end of the relationship I think you
already know that it is incumbent upon
men to make something out of themselves
right it is our job to put some sort of
a dent in the universe and and and chase
some form of Excellence now yeah you
don't do this for her you don't do this
her you do it for you as a consequence
of that a woman or women will be
attracted to you it may be her it may be
other women okay it feels like it takes
a minute to put a dent in the universe
you know I was when she met
me I was making good money and I like
stop stop stop stop cutting me off let
me finish what I'm say oh sorry okay I
apologize okay of course it takes more
than a minute to be successful every o
every overnight success I'm doing that
in quotations is like a 10year time
frame again you know like my entire
YouTube channel on entrepreneurs and
cars is documented almost over 10 years
just just over nine and a half years now
the 10y year anniversary will be May
next year okay that that that success
that overnight success took, 1500
uploaded videos plus the other 3,000
that I probably never uploaded because I
didn't like them or I thought they were
[__] or I didn't like the message or the
editing sucked or something the computer
crashed when I was doing something right
there's all that work that went into it
right so yeah it's going to take more
than a minute to find that next big
thing for you but You' done this before
you know how to do things you know how
to be successful you know how to do the
work stop worrying about what she thinks
about you stop listening to your
[__] about get out of the house
you're a bum any of that stuff [__] all
that find out what it is that you love
doing that you're good at doing and that
it makes money and then go and do that
[__] yeah okay yeah I appreciate that
and if she wants around and if she wants
to be a compliment to your life and she
she wants to be friendly you know all of
those things then keep her around but I
think but I don't know if she's gonna
have the patience to wait till I put you
know won't she probably won't already
formed this opinion of you in her mind
her colleag her her councel of women
yeah her colleagues have already helped
her form this opinion of you she's
looking for a way out the clock is
ticking down to the end of this I really
hope you guys enjoyed that clip if you
want to watch the full length podcast
you can find that over here that clip's
from if you're new to the Channel make
sure you hit subscribe over here and pin
down below in the top comment you'll
find a bunch of useful links to my
website my supplement line books and a
bunch of other stuff have an amazing day
peace out